well with a spike in poison control
calls local health officials are warning
of people taking an unauthorized
so-called treatment for covid that's
instead having some pretty dangerous
consequences the food and drug
administration even tweeting this quote
you are not a horse you are not a cow
seriously y'all stop it
the i-team's david charns here now with
what poison control is seeing david yeah
denise we're talking about ivermectin a
drug not approved to treat or prevent
covid but is approved to treat parasites
and animals particularly large ones like
horses and that is prompting people to
go to the store go online the feed store
we're talking about for animals buy this
stuff and then call for help later
it's the stupidest thing i've ever heard
that's horse owner leonard sanchez's
reaction to people buying medication
meant for large animals to treat covid19
it even says on there
if swallowed you need to see a doctor
don't
the same way with bleach it says on it
why would you swallow bleach from bleach
to a horse dewormer called ivermectin
some people purchasing the drug meant
for one thousand pound animals like
melanie ingesting it and getting sick i
don't know that i was surprised
disappointed i think
and a little worried more than anything
veterinary and a.j manship at desert
pines equine medical and surgical center
showed us what it looks like that's not
even a full syringe and some people are
eating it all up bottom line it's not
approved for what people are using it
for these medicines have side effects
they might interact with your current
medications and so there's definitely
risk in trying to self-treat using
things that haven't been
prescribed for you shireen banerjee is
the director of the nevada poison center
she says before the pandemic there were
no calls for ivermectin exposure now
they've had four but the fact that it
was zero the year before
it's significant if that trend continues
i'm worried about more of the general
public doing the same thing
buying something
that has not been
prescribed for them and then running
into trouble trouble starting on the
internet whether it's an online order or
misinformation i know
covet is scary lockdowns are scary right
but this isn't the way to get past that
now some forms of ibramectin are
approved to treat parasites in us humans
but that's not what you can buy online
or at a feed store and you need to go
through a doctor now there aren't many
good studies about its use against covet
either and the fda says there's no
evidence right now that ivermectin
especially in large doses we just showed
you is helpful at all i'm david charns 8
news now denise david thanks for that
warning tonight so we do want to get
that nevada poison control number out
there just in case you or someone you
know needs it just put it up on the
refrigerator that number is on your
screen it's 1-800-222
and always in an emergency just call
9-1-1